now emmy award-winning actress kirstie
alley is facing intense backlash tonight
from the left after she announced her
support for president trump
joining us now to explain is actress
kirstie alley well
first of all you're brave to come on
this show i give you a lot of credit
you will be hit hard uh prepare yourself
welcome to my world
you know it's it's the water's warm you
should rot in hell
um you don't have a brain they've
attacked
your deeply held and personal religious
beliefs
um why why do you think it's that
vicious they really
you know they always attack the same
three things that you know i'm a fat
irrelevant scientologist so but you know
this has been going on for 40
years so i i'm sort of prepared that
really
is basically all they they have to offer
so i honestly don't take it too
personally because i feel that people
are angry and they have the right to say
what they want to say
and i have the right to block them if i
don't like the way they speak but
and why did it happen you know it's
funny because i've been talking about
trump now
for several months and uh the other
night i i
put out a tweet that simply said that i
voted for him the first time in this
time because he's not a politician so
then i got all this flood i think
thousands and thousands going
do you know the definition of politician
do you know what a politician is do you
know what he does
and i do and i know they know what i
meant and what i meant was that he's not
a career politician
and you know we have a history in this
country
of uh of people
not as much currently but of people of
different occupations like
farmers and tailors and oil men
and businessmen and generals coming in
and servicing our country as the
president of the united states and even
many of them when they left they went
back to their
their other job so i like that trump has
a lot of energy i like that he he has
more energy than any human being i've
actually ever seen and i think that the
big thing that i was mentioning in that
tweet was that i'm really tired of
career politicians i'm tired of
paying people to do nothing and take way
too long to do it
and i feel like they have a this is what
i would do to solve this
sean they have they should have a base
salary
and then they uh they should be paid
if they uh have any accomplishments like
they should have a base salary and for
every accomplishment
yeah free don't hold your breath a
performance bonus
kind of like a talker you you you spoke
out very i read your twitter
feed you know you're against socialism
you're against career politicians
you also said something you took on joe
biden which very few people will take on
and that was on the issue of race
he praised as his friend and mentor a
former klansman
he partnered with that former klansmen
to stop the integration of schools
because he didn't want his kids going to
schools that were racial jungles
why does hollywood accept that if you're
a liberal democrat
which they'd never accept from anybody
else
i don't know i that's it's why i you
know have to just think for myself
because you know when your gaffes are
constantly
you know when he said you know um
what did he say you ain't black if
you're not voting for me and then these
constant
gaffs that have these actual
racist overtones and i'm like no maybe
you get one where you accidentally
said something inappropriate oh it's not
one it's pretty constant
let me just say this biggest deal with i
mean it is
constant isn't it those are race racial
slurs
let me just say you have a lot of
courage i admire you for doing it
and i can accept liberal views they
ought to be able to accept
our views but they can't thank you
kirsty best of luck